in your production company is house of
pendant yes okay yes when did you form
it 1010 2010 okay do you remember what
was sort of the inciting incident or
spark in your mind where you said this
is I want to not only be in films but
also be behind them be a decision maker
yes yes certainly thank you for that
question you know me being in the United
States I was getting some wonderful
acting offers back in india and i had
not explored even explored the hollywood
landscape not that I'm saying I would
have gotten into it easily i'm not
saying that but i haven't even explored
that because i had enough of a
professional life in the states to start
yet another avenue of explorations so I
was sticking with India you know my
original so I was getting a ton of
acting offers but every single time they
said oh can you come and we can maybe
finalize you next week I would have
given my schedule into the hospital for
my work so and those as you know in the
creative field it's all random calls you
you can't really plan those things you
know director team producer team come
together they say why don't we cast
Kalpana let us call her they call me and
yes oh where am I so I lost out on a ton
of roles like that you know because but
I am NOT regretting that because what i
am doing in this part of my life was
tremendous certainly not regretting that
but I was trying okay what am I going to
do at some point there should be a
better way of doing this you know so
that's when I thought what about
creating myself you know and that it was
a scary thought believe me and but I got
wonderful support at that point I got
wonderful support from people who I
connected to in India from my people
friends your day everybody said yeah do
it you only live once you know that's
your dream try it do it and that's how
that dream began I mean it wasn't any
more dramatic than that so I i got my
company incorporated and
the director sandeep Milani who's done
Jojo lolly is another brilliantly
creative individual I've worked with him
now in three films this third film is
also his direction so Lagasse Kadaga you
will see how brilliantly is made it so
he came up with the that the business
angle of it he said he will do it very
minimally for me so he gave me great
confidence that I would not be you know
wasting resources in a field which I
didn't know anything about so I trusted
that and then I gave him elements of the
story and he created this beautiful
narrative and he brought together the
team it was it was entirely the team was
his creation but the role he gave me was
brilliant that of a young mother who is
who falls in love with a philandering
photographer and gets infected she
doesn't know it he leaves her she is
pregnant with his child gives birth and
she's a happy single mother living her
life with a beautiful four-year-old four
years later he is diagnosed with HIV and
that's when she realizes that he got it
from her and and then she loses the
child and then what happens how that
story of hope comes about that that we
didn't end it with the sadness we we
showed that yes still you can live still
you can go forward still you can impact
lives and help people even though you
lost your own you know so that is how we
began our journey with production
you